JAKE ARCHIBALD: Hello.
This is Google I/O. And this
is "Coffee with a Googler."
I am sitting on a chair.
But that doesn't really matter.
Because on the sofa next
to me is Alex Komoroske.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Yep.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Are
you having a good time?
Enjoying--
ALEX KOMOROSKE: I'm
having an amazing time.
There's all kinds of--
every year it's different.
And so they have all these
interesting swing sets
and stuff.
It's pretty cool.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So what's
your job title then?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: I am the
Product Management Lead
on Chrome's web platform team.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
That's quite long.
So I would shorten that.
I kind of think of you as a
sort of Web Hero or Champion
of the Web.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Oh, OK.
Sure.
I like that.
That sounds good.
Let's go with that.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So why the web?
What is the web to you?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So I-- I
think like a lot of people--
have had this long, deep
connection with the web.
So I shared yesterday
this embarrassing story
about the Real Ultimate
Power and actually
how we uploaded a picture of
our crew team posing for that.
But for me, it
actually really became
sort of an important moral
issue for me in college,
when I read this book,
"The Wealth of Networks,"
by Yochai Benkler, who's a
professor at Yale or something.
And it totally sold
me on the power
for society of these
open systems or whatever.
But all of this, I guess,
is really abstract.
And so I think
one of the reasons
I love the web is that it
makes it really easy for you
to reach a lot of
people with your stuff,
and get your ideas out there.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
And part of it for
me as well, I guess,
is that, and the openness of it.
One of the things that
really got me into the web
was View Source.
I was able to go and see, wow.
This is a thing on
the web-- View Source.
Wow.
That's how it's
being put together.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Yeah.
And it's great for tinkerers.
Because you don't need to
get anyone's permission.
You don't need to buy anything.
You can just use a text editor
that comes onto your computer,
and get into it that way.
That's totally how I started.
That's how I bet a lot
of us started on it.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
I know we have a bit of a
back and forth or banter
with the Android guys.
And the Hello World for
Android comes in at like 800k.
I think they've got it down to
whereas Hello World on the web
is Hello World, right?
It's just a text
bubble with that.
Upload that somewhere
and off you go.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Yeah.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So you gave
a talk yesterday morning
on the next generation
of the mobile web.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: That's right.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: And I remember
Web 2.0 from a few years ago.
It was a kind of marketing
thing with no substance.
ALEX KOMOROSKE:
So actually, I've
found that for those kinds
of things, the terms, when
they're really successfu-- some
things are just always hot air.
Right?
They start as hot air.
They end as hot air.
But some things that are
actually really something
meaningful then
become so meaningful
that everyone who
doesn't understand them
starts using those words.
So like AJAX--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Oh my god, yes.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: AJAX
was totally a thing.
Right?
It totally meant
something very specific.
And then all these CEOs
and marketing people said,
oh yeah, AJAX.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Can
we make it AJAX?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Like,
cool web things.
And so it lost its meaning.
And meanwhile, we're sitting
here like, that's not AJAX.
What does that mean?
That's silly.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yes
it's asynchronous.
Yes, it's JavaScript.
We can go with that.
What is it?
I think it's not XML.
It's very rarely XML.
And it all sort of
fell down from there.
It just came to mean anything
vaguely asynchronous.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: But to me,
Web 2.0 is the same way.
Yeah, it's a buzzword.
It totally has
become a buzz word.
But the fact of the
matter is there's
a number of amazingly
successful companies
that got their start
during that time.
And so now, we look back.
And we're like, oh,
yeah, Web 2.0, whatever.
But it actually was-- all
of these really successful
companies that we totally
take for granted today
totally got their start
because of the web.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
And because companies are asking
for, can we make this, uh,
the second web rather
than the first web?
It's like, oh, yeah.
Yeah.
So what you essentially
mean there is you
want it to be a bit
faster and a bit simpler.
And that was a good excuse,
I think, for us as developers
to sort of crowbar
some of what we wanted.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Absolutely.
Because I think with
the earlier web,
everyone had this,
like, oh, what?
Static sites-- things are slow.
You click.
It takes a while to load.
And there really wasn't
any reason at that point,
because techniques like
AJAX and XMLHttpRequest
allowed you to build
these immersive things.
And so actually,
a new label really
helped developers go
with it and find that.
And the same way, I think,
is what we're at now.
People say, oh my gosh.
Look, this native app
loads so much faster.
It's like, well, look
at the web's version!
They just took this huge 25
megs required to download it.
It's got 13 different third
party scripts, many of which
are calculating the same
stuff with synchronous layouts
on every scroll event.
Of course that's not fast.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So how's the
next generation of the web
different?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: I think
it's people really learning
how to use some of
these new technologies,
and how to build things
that feel at home on mobile.
So using the
[INAUDIBLE] framework
that we talked about,
to help understand
when you have good
performance, and when
you should be optimizing, and
when you add an extra script
to your site.
And you go, no.
You know what?
That made my site load too
slow or scroll too slowly.
I'm not to include it.
It's not worth it.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: That's
one of the things
I'm hearing sort of becoming
more and more popular.
And it's music to my ears.
It's the idea of having
a performance budget
as part of your design process.
And that's a big
part of [INAUDIBLE].
ALEX KOMOROSKE: It truly is.
Because if you
wait until the end
and try to make it highly
performant, it's too late.
So what you really want
to do is build something
fast from the beginning.
And as you layer in things,
make sure you don't ever
regress your performance.
That's one of the
reasons that we're
looking forward to doing things
in DevTools, to make it easier.
So right now, when
you open up DevTools,
you're like, overwhelmed.
Right?
And there's so much there.
And that's why we're
looking into tools that
will make it much more-- hey.
We looked at your page.
Your reaction time
is pretty good.
Load time could be better.
Animation speed-- terrible.
You were missing.
You were always janking.
This third party
script right here
is doing way too much work
on every scroll event.
Take it out.
And that would make it much
easier for you to go, oh, OK.
Take it out.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah,
because this is the thing.
The web is fast
by default. Right?
If you have a blank
page-- pretty fast.
It's all regression.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Exactly.
And I think also, by the
way, everyone goes, well,
native apps flow much faster.
Well, again, well-made
native apps definitely
can load very quickly.
Well-made web apps can as well.
But remember, you're comparing
the first visit to a website--
you're downloading all of
the images and resources
to display this on the
screen-- versus a thing
where, when you
installed the native app,
it did take a while to download.
In fact, it probably took
a minute or so to download.
It's just that you did
it at install time.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
Many megabytes.
And if you're on
3G, it's normally
like, ah, I'm going to have
to download this later.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Right.
And it gets past
that 10-second mark.
So you say, yeah,
I'll install this.
You know what, I'm going to go
over and play some solitaire
or something.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I'm data
roaming at the moment.
And I'm locked down to 3G.
So I'm completely aware
of that right now.
So it's not just
about the improvements
in the next generation web.
We're getting new
features, as well, right?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Absolutely.
So things-- one of the ones
we're most excited about
is push notifications.
So on mobile in
particular, increasingly
we're moving from
this world where
it's driven by the grid of
apps and into more things that
happen in context.
So actually, just
before we started this,
I got a notification on my
watch about some breaking news
that happened from [INAUDIBLE].
And I was able to interject it
in conversation, because I just
glanced at it on my watch.
That actually came from our
website, which is really cool.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: But even
though it's on your watch--
and we don't run
Chrome on the watches.
But it's--
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Yeah.
So Chrome running on my Android
device got the notification.
And then it's just a
normal system notification.
So it showed up on my watch.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
That's brilliant.
So if I visit-- I get
sent a link by someone.
I'll go to that website.
And one of the things
I like about the web
is I don't have to think, ooh.
Do I trust this website
before clicking the link?
But to be able to do
notifications and things,
there's code running
in the background.
So what kind of
protection-- is there
a break in the security
of the web here?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: That is
a really critical point.
And everyone goes, ah, you
should just copy native apps.
Native apps do some
things extremely well.
The web-- one of its biggest
and most important strengths
is how easy it is for
people to navigate
to a diverse collection
of stuff so easily.
So if you are
afraid to tap links,
that would be a total failure.
Right?
Because that's the
benefit of the web.
In fact, yesterday we
shared that on average,
Chrome for Android users visit
100 distinct domains a month
on average, which is crazy.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Which is more
than most people have apps.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Oh, way over.
And it's because
it's so easy for you
to dive into these things.
So that's incredibly
important for us to maintain.
So the way that it works
is you visit a site.
And what we encourage
developers to do
is, in context,
explain to the users
why they might want
push notifications.
So say for example you
visit "The Guardian."
You've read multiple
articles on a given topic.
And they say, hey, at the
end, you like this topic.
Would you like to be
notified when there's
more articles on this topic?
Well, yes.
Yes I would.
You tap that on.
And then of course,
Chrome verifies.
Hey, "Guardian" would love
to send you notifications.
Just to make sure that you
knew what you were doing.
And at that point,
if you say yes,
they'll allow them to
register for notifications.
But there's an
important bit to this.
Then say you register.
And it says, this sounds good.
You register.
And they send you a
notification every minute.
We also make it very easy.
In each notification we show,
there's a prominent site
settings button.
You tap that.
It's just a couple
more taps to turn off
notifications for that domain.
So we make it very easy for
you to revoke that permission
if you decide that that
site wasn't using it
in a respectful way.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: That's
excellent, as well.
Because we've been
building a few test
apps with this technology.
And just because there's just
a button that sends a push
message to someone else, I've
sort of woken up in the morning
with like 100 of these.
And it's just so good
that it's like, right.
Actually, I'm done with this.
We've had our fun.
Yeah.
So back to safety, you're
able to just revoke
those permissions.
And you're back to it just
being like any other website.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Right.
And again, I think
that's what's so
important about this feature.
It's everyone goes, yeah.
You've got push
notifications in apps.
But remember, websites--
you visit so many of them.
It's so easy to stumble
across other things.
And instead of having
this all or nothing-- do
you want to fully
commit to this thing?
Give it space on
your home screen?
Give it all these
powerful permissions?
Nah.
I just want push notifications.
You know, I check
into this airline.
I don't fly them very often.
I don't want their
app necessarily.
I don't fly them that often.
But it says, do you want to be
notified if your gate changes?
Why, yes.
Yes I would.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yes.
Because exactly that case.
It's not something that
you visit every day.
But that notification
is so important to you.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Exactly.
It's critical.
And so I think we're
combining this amazing reach,
this no-commitment for
the web, and allowing you
as a user to sort of
escalate, on your own terms,
as you feel comfortable.
You pick and choose which
aspects of the experience
you want.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So the
whole push messaging thing
is one of the features
that's from native, right?
When I think of the
apps on my home screen,
the native apps, the reason
they-- well, previously
to now-- couldn't have
been done on the web
is because of push
notifications.
ALEX KOMOROSKE:
That's a big one.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: As the web,
are we just copying native?
Are we always going to be behind
and just picking and choosing
their innovations?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: I
don't think that would
be a good way for us to go.
And so, yes.
We look at the
features, the things
that people are relying
on on these devices.
And we figure out a way to
bring it responsibly to the web.
But at every point, we're trying
to marry these capabilities
with the power of
the web-- this reach.
And so for example,
background sync
is a functionality that
native apps often have.
They can sort of wake
up in the background,
refreshen their resources.
Why don't we just
bring this to the web?
Well, it's actually really hard.
So imagine that you
visit a site every day
on your personal computer.
It's an embarrassing
celebrity gossip site
that you don't want to admit
to anybody that you visit.
You go often.
You never would
visit that at work,
because you're
supposed to be working.
Right?
So you visit it.
And then we say, OK, cool.
You visit this pretty often.
Let's let you
background sync that.
Well, now you go to
your work network.
And it syncs in the background.
And your boss goes,
Jake, what are you doing?
Why are you wasting time
on the company network?
So that's just-- we have
to think very carefully
about these things, to
make sure that users have
the right expectations
about what's happening,
so the right things can happen,
and they don't inadvertently
waste the battery or leak
personal information,
or what have you.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: And it made
me really happy in the keynote
to hear that Android's
permissioning model--
that they're changing to
what you mentioned before,
this kind of just-in-time
contextual permissioning model.
So I've kind of thought
that's a case where, hey.
They've kind of copied the
success of the web, which
I thought was great.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: I
think there's a lot
of great properties of apps
and the way the web works.
And I think it's great for them
to be inspired by one another
to try to figure
out how to bring
these lessons from the
other realm into the other,
and just make it
better for everybody.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
I think it's great to see the
web progressing and getting
all of these new
features, but still
staying true to the
benefits of the web.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Right, right.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
Mr. Alex Komoroske,
talking about the next
generation mobile web.
Thank you very
much for watching.